olá pessoal
é um prazer é essa história é uma
história muito doida porque eu falar
sobre dependência química né mas a minha
primeira frase é que droga é bom pra
caramba
é impressionante a mais assim é muito
bom é tão bom porque se fosse ruim eu
tinha parado lá atrás há 14 anos atrás
eu parei com tudo mas assim no começo
parecia tudo bom
se eu pudesse traçar uma linha é o
começo muito bom depois uma linha de mão
dupla onde começa a ficar ruim
no final uma derrocada geral mas assim a
dependência química o que quer
dependência química a doença sem cura
progressiva e não sai no exame de sangue
então é uma doença diferente você tem
que aceitar que você está doente
alguém falou pra você que geralmente à
noite com você fala se você está pegando
pesado porque eu e você não olha eu não
sei por que você tá afim
então é de uma certa maneira tem que
entender um pouco como começa isso a
compulsão é tudo ligado à compulsão e eu
vou um cara que comecei a glamourizar a
droga o álcool a maconha a cocaína é em
casa tem gente que começa com a turma do
colégio a turma da praia e tal eu
comecei em casa porque meu irmão mais
velho irmão mais velho é o mais velho de
cinco anos e minha irmã quatro anos
eles conheciam na década lá por 1975
toda a galera do rock toda a galera da
da música em geral e do surf
imagina a década de 70 e tal era eu era
um poucochinho desenhava e tal ainda não
tinha começado a tocar violão e era
fascinado pelo aquele mundo libertário
de elite do surfe de conhecer o rio de
janeiro inteiro e isso de uma certa
maneira me e me deu se um o globo eles
eram muse dos meus irmãos
tia minha que levava os novos baianos
até a casa de petrópolis
e eu vi eles tocando e fumando maconha o
tempo inteiro e os amigos do meio moda e
da minha irmã também ao mesmo tempo que
a galera ia pra casa dos meus pais shape
a prancha na garagem da casa que era uma
casa do lado de uma máquina de lavar
roupa cheia de carreira estendida de
cocaína
então obviamente que eu vendo isso com
10 anos 11 anos e tal eu meio que
desmistifiquei de uma certa maneira e
achava como eles são meus ídolos então e
são meus heróis eu eu também acho que
isso deve ser legal né e seguir por esse
caminho não na mesma hora com dez anos
mas assim eu comecei a aprender violão
com 11 anos para aprender bittles ibope
gelo e aí eu comecei a tocar violão e os
amigos meus irmãos da mesma sabil muitos
sabiam tocar violão
a irmã começou a namorar o traficante
quando tinha 14 anos e um de 17 e é um
cara que eu idolatrava porque ele me
ensinava tudo chegava em casa eu já pedi
para me ensinar o advogado da selação
enfim qualquer coisa dos beatos que
fosse necessário e ele é um cara muito
bacana e tal e ela se envolveu nisso
cedo lá em casa só três dependentes
químicos devem renovar a linha para 17
18 anos me mata limpa 23 anos e eu estou
chegando agora próximo em 14 anos
limpo mas a verdade é que é gradativo e
eu comecei a tocar violão e comecei a me
envolver um pouco mais com a história do
rock do glamour do rock
então não é o tio glamour dos meus
irmãos chegou do ó kit glamour do surf
eu comecei a fazer esportes e da pega
onda a jogar bola é a foi bicampeão
carioca de squash então tinha o lado
esportivo sport desportista legal bacana
que me segurava o talma e comecei a
brincar e subestimar um pouco pediu para
experimentar um baseado aos 14 anos de
idade
não gostei muito da primeira vez estava
com os amigos meu irmão me apresentou
e aí no dia seguinte pediu outro já vê
apertado e aí
é a cheia engraçado e divertir achei
legal porque se fosse ruim tinha parado
mesmo então comecei a fumar
desmistifiquei de uma certa maneira a
droga e entrei na puc com 17 anos de
idade enquanto isso fui aprendendo
violou podia tocar baixo o time às
primeiras bandas comecei a fazer show
comecei a ter minha própria turma é e
comecei a gostar do rock'n'roll e gostar
da história do rock o dos meus heróis
que depois morreram de overdose ou que
já tinham morrido e eu tava naquele meio
entrando naquele meio mas a culpa não
era do meio a dependência química é
muito individual compulsão individual
então eu não sabia direito onde estava
me metendo até porque não sai no exame
de sangue não tem uma linha divisória do
gramado onde você acorde sou dependente
químico europa não tem então eu fui indo
e brincando subestimando glamorizando
substimando a droga e os meus irmãos
mais velhos eram meus ídolos então eu
comecei a tocar minha própria tua mãe
pra rua da ajuda de repente assim a
maconha virou uma coisa lá em secundária
junto com álcool e eu fui para a rua da
ajuda várias vezes e os 19 anos
eu já tinha entrado na puc fazer uma
faculdade de administração de empresas
seguir talvez o espaço do meu pai que
era o diretor do estaleiro é maquinista
naval amanhã fonoaudiólogo meus pais não
usavam drogas mas toda a família ao
redor de uma certa maneira usava e eu
era o primeiro músico da família
primeiro começou a tocar então eu fui
autodidata tive poucas aulas e tal e
comecei a ter uma banda uma banda minha
de rock tal eu 19 estava errado ajuda de
cocaína ea cocaína caiu como uma luva
assim pra mim eu já estava meio parado
de fumar maconha ou então ea cocaína
decidiu se estava no maior cartão postal
de arraial d'ajuda que atrás da igreja
com um visual todo que tem na praia eu
comecei a tocar era o violeiro de
fogueira inveterada que toca de beto
guedes a pink floyd ganhou seis e
comecei a tocar tocar aquilo adormeceu
na gargante eu tô que horas eu pedi era
uma tia minha que estava do lado e eu
penso que é isso aí estava com
mas não é porque o bico não eu falei não
passa pra cá tava eu tava joão estrela
do filme meu nome não é johnny e teve
essa história para onde foram
então é eu comecei a gostar mas só
cheguei seis meses depois uma festa na
hípica no rio e ali eu descobrir o
banheiro quando fui no banheiro no
banheiro feminino sempre tem fila enorme
o banheiro masculino é mais rápido
parecia mas esse banheiro demorava horas
eu pensei por que demorou tanto é que há
poucos a 15 do banheiro cheirando
cocaína e eu entrei também com mais 15
cheirando e os meses depois de novo a
mesma coisa nessa época comecei a tocar
com o ppm 15 a metade que não gostavam
disso começamos a pegar onda junto jogar
bola e tal emendei joão penca léo jaime
e 86 87 88 quando já mito o filme rock
estrela nos cinemas a história da sua
agente é oito músicas na rádio a gente
tocando cinco shows por semana e também
não tinha muita cocaína ali alguns
episódios isolados e equipe técnica um
pouco da banda em manaus eu me lembro da
gente possui o bateu uma das primeiras
impressões da minha vida lá e tal mas
seguindo e 88 léo jaime parou de fazer
show lobão me chamou pra tocar com ele
fui tocar com lobão
e aí a turma também se encaixou legal e
todo mundo a banda o próprio bolas todos
éramos uma família
gravamos dvd no morumbi para 90 mil
pessoas que gravamos o disco em los
angeles fizemos milhões de coisas e um
com 24 anos por aírton e era super legal
vários discos e tal mas ali já começou a
bater a outra linha a linha que vai
volta eu comecei a chegar em casa morava
com meus pais quando chegar meio
deprimido é ficava na cama se meio meio
triste porque não consigo que coisa
estranha se essa depende da cocaína
quanto mais sobe mais desce nessa
verdade senão trânsito ali então eu ali
já comecei a sentir alguns sinais assim
né
mas nada como a minha irmã já tinha
passado problemas e achado uma clínica e
tentamos recuperar o meu irmão também
estava com problemas e eu acho que cada
um tem um estilo de vida diferente meio
rock errou eu sou um rockstar vou seguir
os rolling stones led zeppelin sciotti
quem for então continuei e entrei no
barão vermelho 92 e no barão
eu como artista com mais
responsabilidade disco e entrevistas e
tal segurei um pouco ao ano no começo
depois foi aumentando de novo uso até
chegar em 2004 quando chegou em 2004 é
eu tive uma chance o o o avião que foi
quase morri
eu vi teto preto achei que eu vomitei de
campinas a recife teria a pé do rio
salvador é mas eu fui vomitei de
campinas e recife
todos aqui de fome do avião tem um
médico a bordo eu só vi esse filme de
repente era pra mim o médico ficará que
existe um médico a bordo - é verdade
ele chegou na minha na minha frente foi
uma boa noite ó ele foi enfim fui para o
hospital
se o festival para 60 mil pessoas eu fui
pro festival tomar água de coco e depois
para o hospital tomar soro e 40 minutos
isso é um sinal 2004 as mesmas já tinha
feito rock in rio todos os festivais
possível e aí cheguei perto de final de
2004 ali eu já comecei a outra situação
aconteceu mais umas três é muita
situação pra contar e minuciosamente
pelo tempo que a gente tem mas o a
verdade eu comecei a ficar muito
deprimido deprimido já e aí já tinha
nascido um filho meu que está com 20
anos agora eu parei quando eu tinha
cinco anos de idade
eu estou casado há 23 anos poderia ter
perdido o casamento poderia ter perdido
o trabalho mas eu quase me pedir eu não
só vou pedir porque eu parei a tempo
então eu fui um dia para teresópolis
e nesse dia foi o dia final onde os
barões falaram pra mim não quero você
para o tá fora porque eu sei que
teresópolis e petrópolis para pegar pó e
tal eu estava acostumado a fazer isso e
nesse dia e já tinha passado duas
situações é o quarto em casa olhando
para o teto falou assim cara não tem
mais saída
acho que eu vou matar acabar com esse
sofrimento é desesperador
o vício da cocaína o vício da droga
acho que eu experimentei é desesperador
é tá numa teia de aranha é pague para
entrar e reze para sair
estava lá eu no quarto assim vou ligar
para o sac taxista me levar a ponte
rio-niterói eu conheço o cara aí eu peço
pra apoio ao banheiro no meio da ponte é
impossível isso é proibido
mas eu pensava na cabeça doentia isso é
uma doença que eu poderia pular não
devam menor porque o goleiro dá errado e
mandou maior é o pai morreu logo que
acaba com o sofrimento no amor chega nem
o telefone e parado assim beleza
procurei ajuda depois de uma reunião do
barão vermelho falando que como eu
parava contudo eu estava fora da bola
porque estava com medo que eu morresse
tava com medo de me perder até
emocionante porque meus amigos dizendo
que estava com minha tia me perdi e eu
aceitei entrar no tratamento no hospital
dia 30 sem dúvida todo dia eu tinha que
ir pra lá e voltar de noite assistir a
reuniões voltar a assistir no primeiro
mês eu gravei dvd do barão com 18 dias
de abstinência circo voador todo mundo
doido pra caramba lidando com champanha
com a gravadora e eu ali assim é pra
casa e fui com minha mulher é foi
kombarov estados unidos com um mês de
abstinência
já no tratamento o centro vida
não bebi não fiz nada ligava pra minha
terapeuta suzana gazeta você olha é tá
tudo certo fui para inglaterra com dois
meses para gravar um dvd dos britos sua
banda the beats que eu tinha que fazer
comecei a tocar por causa de bianca
estava na disneylândia do rock
a disneylândia dos bichos e eu tava ali
todo bebendo chope tulipas desse tamanho
e eu fui com a minha mulher conhecemos e
os cafés é o brechó vão que legal existe
vida além dos bares maravilha tocando no
cavern club várias vezes e e ali foi
interessante porque é a agente
engravidou quer dizer minha mulher
engravidou eu participei é da situação e
aí nasceu nosso segundo filho quando eu
um ano depois
mas eu volto pro brasil mix o dvd dos
britos morre o jaderson doutor jadílson
que o que salvou minha vida já de açúcar
o filho
fique atenta da clínica ele morreu
fazendo o terceiro aos 51 anos de idade
eu me utilizei disso pra continuar o
tratamento falou assim eu vou provar
para ele que eu vou ficar limpa até o
final da minha vida eu sei que um dia de
cada vez
eu sei que é matar um leão por dia mas
isso também a gente vai avançando a cada
dia vai melhorando e as conquistas foram
surgindo então a partir da linha do 10
meses e foi indicada a coordenação de
reuniões na clínica certo dia eu
coordenei durante três anos e coordenará
era difícil como está aqui agora uma
galera e eu tenho que encarar um caso ou
outro as pessoas estão chegando os que
têm mais tempo de abstinência ao mesmo
tempo orgulhoso de ter sido indicado
pelo grupo pelas terapeutas pelo pelo
pessoal do centro vida e coordenei três
anos e as conquistas desses desse tempo
todo de 2 de agosto de 2005 até o dia de
hoje foram tantos que eu não posso
enumerar aqui que eu vou demorar horas
mas foram quatro rock isso em carreira
solo
mais de 2.500 disco solo de adiar shows
da 14 discos quatro dvds um livro que a
minha biografia uma turnê com eles na
verdade já a quinta turnê com eles anos
que está isso de polícia junto com joão
barone dos paralamas do sucesso
a gente está rodando o mundo
além dos meus 20 shows por mês que eu
faça a festa rock
quer dizer foi muita eu fiz 70 letras da
primeira semana que eu parei com tudo 70
letra eu faço uma letra por balão de 98
do desporto e se perde em 2005 fiz 70 na
primeira semana já agora já são dez dias
enfim é só ganhos então sim inúmera
esses ganhos eu sei que eu
todo mundo tem saída
vi muita gente morrer
vi muita gente morrer recaindo mas é é
uma doença recaído ela faz parte da
doença e do tratamento e eu coloquei na
minha cabeça que um dia de cada vez e em
seguir em frente
meu caminho e eu fui construindo coisas
né
sem construir coisas têm que ser era
compulsivo para me destruir agora você
com o possível para me construir essa
turnê com eles ambas por exemplo é me
deixa nervoso sobe pela argentina do
chile cantar de polícia com o ícone mas
de repente sou eu a fazê lo eu não troco
o pior o pior dia da minha crença pelo
melhor dia da loucura um troco pra mim
não tem preço não tem negociação a vida
é a vida o mesmo cara que tava olhando
para o teto pensando em se matar e
pulado da ponte rio niterói
daqui hoje falando para vocês com o
cartaz na porta de si mesmo teatro
anunciando uma nova turnê com a edição e
com joão barone o qual de polícia mais
um projeto que eu tenho além do faz
parte do meu show com menescal com a
leila pinheiro casos em bossa 9 milhões
de coisas que eu crio três livros que
estou escrevendo
então a vida pra mim não tem por isso eu
a partir de agora a minha missão é
valorizar a vida eu paguei pela minha
mulher e os meus filhos por mim e por
tudo que eu posso construir de acordo
com o espaço que eu vou dando daqui pra
frente porque a vida é a vida
[Aplausos]